with the white king to go after black's
pawns
um it's not going to be easy black's
king is temporarily paralyzed he has to
decide
whether it's possible the reason i think
you're concerned about that
is because of this move yeah and uh now
the king takes
because now it's white too slow look
black is too slow sorry yeah
white is too fast here white king is
going to come round and
uh black's pawns will be destabilized
blacks the problem for black is you can
never take
white pawn black's king cannot take that
pawn because the other white pawn would
run up the board
so black's king is pretty much stuck
where it is rajabov he leans back
he just resigns magnus you see the
relief on his face
he has qualified magnus carlsen
in the last game in the preliminaries
getting a win
qualifying for the knockout stage
he must be feeling so relieved right now
yeah i think we saw it
right his reaction there look at that
fantastic a big smile on the world space
he threw to the knockout